the Environment Secretary Michael Gove
joins us mr. Gope here in the Seychelles
they have a marine protected area that
really works plentiful fish healthy
coral real biodiversity why can't we do
more in Britain I think we do need to do
more not just in Britain but worldwide
and that's why the UK is one of those
countries that's committed to making
sure that 30% of the world's oceans are
fully protected by 2030 and we made a
big step forward last week when we
committed to safeguarding the waters
around Ascension Island which is one of
Britain's overseas territories so we're
expanding that blue belt of marine
protected areas and around our own
Shores as well we have a network of
marine protected areas but one of the
things that I'm reviewing is how
effective the protection is because
there are many good people who argue
that we do need to step up the level of
protection in some of those MPAs waters
are protected it'll be 30 percent in a
year or two in Britain it's what sort of
four or five square miles well there's a
there's a variation of the level of
protection around the UK but we are
reviewing exactly how we can improve the
protection of marine life and
biodiversity but it is also the case
that because of Britain's history and
legacy that there are are islands across
the globe for which Britain is
responsible and we've extended marine
protected areas around those so it's not
just a central island but Tristan Cunha
and Pitcairn and others are all parts of
a blue belt of protected areas and that
means that the UK now is I think the
only country in the world where 30% of
the otters under its control are now
fully protected or about to be fully
protected
yes but in the UK I'm talking about the
Bluebell in a number of areas in the
blue belt there's still commercial
fishing there is still dredging dredging
in goodwin sands - you know extend the
port in Dover this is not really a
protected area is it well some areas do
need better protection you're absolutely
right now of course it's the case that
in some marine protected areas fishing
of a particular kind will continue so in
a protected area you're not necessary
getting rid of all economic activity but
we do need to review how extensive the
protections are and a number of people
made some very fair points about the
need to make sure that we provide the
highest possible level of protection in
all the waters that we control and I'm
very sympathetic to that argument so
sympathetic to it can you guarantee that
Britain will have more proper protected
marine areas and soon yes well we are
already as I say making sure that more
and more of the waters that we control
are fully protected I am reviewing the
evidence and will be saying more about
the steps that we propose to take in
order to ensure that we can have there
the highest level possible of protection
so that we can replenish our seas and
make sure that they're teeming with the
fish and the wildlife that you can
observe and enjoy in the Indian Ocean on
the beaches behind me here of Aldabra
there is still tons of plastic being
washed up so plastic remains a real
issue
I shouldn't be Britain shouldn't Britain
be doing more like you know a plastic
bottle deposit scheme that seems to be
working so well in the rest of Europe
for instance yes there's a lot more that
we could do and should do that's what
we're consulting on how a deposit scheme
would work it's why we're extending the
tax or the charge on plastic bags it's
also one of the Chancellor's consulting
on a new tax that means that if you've
got a plastic bottle and it doesn't have
an appropriate amount of recycled
plastic in it then you pay more and of
warrick already it's the case that as a
government we've taken steps to ban the
plastic microbeads that can cause so
much damage in the marine environment
and we're also looking to end the use of
plastic straws stirrers and
Budds which can have a uniquely damaging
impact on marine wildlife you seem to be
consulting on a lot of things keep
saying it sympathetic about doing things
why don't you just get on with it and do
it because delaying is things that we
adapted or contributing to the severe
damage in the oceans it is one of the
things in government that whenever a new
ideas put forward you always have to
consult to make sure that it works well
and lands appropriately if you rush
ahead with laws without consultation
then you can sometimes find that you've
identified the problem but not got the
perfect solution but certainly in the
Euro since I've been Environment
Secretary the Prime Minister has been
clear that we want to go further than
many other countries we've gone further
than the European Union in some of the
bans and restrictions on plastic that we
have and I think we've gone further than
any other developed nation and the
amount of or the range of ocean under
our control that is now fully protected
what needs more consultation about a
bottle deposit scheme it works in
Scandinavian countries it works in
Germany their recycling rates are
significantly higher yes and that's one
of the reasons why we're also going to
move towards a different form of
recycling you have a problem in this
country that we have a patchwork quilt
of different types of recycling and we
also don't have effective recycling of
food waste we put forward plans to
improve that and use some of the money
that would be gained from a plastic tax
in order to ensure that we can have
uniform recycling the situation in the
past is not being good enough and that's
why we're taking action now
all right non climate changed more
broadly isn't it clear that more needs
to be done I mean you've got school
children walking out of class to protest
the lack of action by the government in
Britain by you yes I know I sympathise
with those children who who have brought
home to all of us to my generation how
much more needs to be done to to tackle
the problem of climate change I should
say that I don't approve of children
taking time out of school for it for any
reason but I do think that that passion
that drives them is admirable now there
are some things that the UK has done of
all the world's developed countries
we're the one that's done most to cut
our own carbon emissions over the last
ten years or so but we need to look at
how we farm how we produce energy how we
produce concrete and steel in order to
ensure that we're doing everything to
take carbon out of our economy and to
help to avert the increase in global
temperatures that's causing such
environmental damage then why are you
sending out mixed messages by cutting
subsidies for solar and cutting
subsidies for electric cars why are you
doing that I don't think we are sending
out mixed messages and we are the world
leader when it comes for example to
global offshore wind and I think that
overall what we have seen is the UK's
economy grow but grow in a way which has
also enabled us to reduce carbon
emissions there is more that we can do
but in order to ensure that we can make
the changes that we need to to urban
transport to construction to agriculture
into all these other areas we need to
have the scientific research and
investment that this government has been
backing not least when it comes to
battery technology and of course the
operation of ultra-low emission vehicles
in other words electric cars
yeah but I go back to the point of
electric cars why cut subsidies if you
want more people in an electric cars
well we're the I think one of the first
countries to say that the internal
combustion engine should be banned you
know no more petrol or diesel cars from
2040 and we're investing significantly
in battery technology and we're also
placing requirements on new developments
to make sure that they have charging
facilities so there are a range of
measures and the impression I get
as Environment Secretary is that some
people think that we're being a little
bit how can I put it tough on people who
drive petrol and diesel cars because of
the pace at which we want to make change
but I think we do need to be changing
weekly and that's why we have set these
stretching targets alright and one point
on the broader issue of two degrees
which is the Paris Accord country
signing up to a limit of two degrees I
mean anywhere near like two degrees
scientists now say that coral and coral
reefs will die coral will die reeves
will disappear
why aren't Britain why isn't written
pushing now for a limit of one point
five well a Britain wants to host the
next sort of follow up to Paris the
conference of parties when countries
come together to discuss climate change
we wanted to do that in 2020 and one of
the reasons we want to do that is we
want to be even more ambitious in how we
tackle the problem of climate change for
precisely the reasons that you mentioned
Locke
okay and I hope you've been seeing the
pictures that we've been showing live
150 meters I just wonder what you made
of them oh they're breathtaking and I
have to congratulate you and Skye for
the work that you've done in order to
make sure that all of us are aware of
how precious our oceans are and how much
we need to do in order to help the
fragile ecosystems upon which we all
depend survive in the future okay so
come down with me
well there are one or two things at the
moment in Westminster that are keeping
me busy but as soon as I can get away I
would love to